-Hi, guys.
Welcome to another edition of
"Tonight Show: At Home Edition."
The sun came out just now,
so I figured it's a perfect time
to maybe do the intro
from outside.
We have a great show tonight,
but before we get into the show,
I just do want to say
it's so tough this week.
It's Thursday.
And I know everyone's at home,
doing their part,
staying at home, which is great.
I just wanted to give a special
shout-out tonight
to New York City,
because we do our show
from Manhattan,
in New York City.
And we're very lucky
to do our show from there.
And, so, I just want to say,
New York City,
you're in my thoughts all the
time, but especially today.
We're losing
a lot of great people --
transit workers,
sanitation workers,
firefighters, police officers,
people that are just
doing their jobs.
And that's all they're doing.
And I just want to let them know
that they will not be forgotten,
and what they're doing is
an amazing job,
and you make our country proud.
So thank you so much.
And just like the sun,
the sun will shine again.
It will.
And we'll be back in the city,
doing the show from there.
We have an amazing show tonight.
My favorites of all time, rap
icons, New York City icons --
speaking of New York --
Ad-Rock and Mike D
from the Beastie Boys
are on the show tonight.
And their charity is
foodbanknyc.org.
Again, thank you,
Winnie, for drawing these.
It kind of looks like
I could have done this one.
Anyway...
But the Beasties have
a story called
"The Beastie Boys Story"
on Apple TV+ this Friday,
coming out.
Also, we have Anna Kendrick,
whose film, "Trolls World Tour,"
is out, also on Friday.
And Universal/DreamWorks did
this cool thing where they're
releasing it through TV
so you don't have to
go to theaters.
I think that's a good move.
Her charity she's working with
is The Trevor Project,
which helps out LGBTQ youth
communities.
And you'll see what they do,
the great stuff,
if you go to that website.
Also, our buddy Sting --
speaking of legends --
stops by to help me
and The Roots out.
We might have forced him
to do it.
Might have.
But you'll see what we do with
classroom instruments --
kind of --
just stuff that we can do
around our house with The Roots.
It's an all-new "Tonight Show."
Let's start it with a monologue.
♪♪
Hi, guys.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
Well, Passover
started last night,
and I heard a lot of
people celebrating
held virtual Seders using Zoom.
It's great if you ever wanted to
watch your grandpa
eat soup from
the perspective of the spoon.
I saw that Pope Francis will be
streaming Easter mass
on YouTube.
You know these
are strange times when
the pope ends Easter mass with,
"Be sure to like and subscribe.
Smash that like button."
-Wait. Was that number 2?
-Yeah.
It certainly was. Frances?
That's right --
Easter is in a few days,
but there is an egg shortage.
Did you hear that? Yeah.
Which means a lot of kids won't
be able to dye eggs.
So if you're a bald dad,
do the right thing --
let your kids color your head.
♪♪
Yesterday, Dr. Fauci
said he doesn't think
that we should
ever shake hands again,
which will be weird when
every job interview
starts with
an awkward chest bump.
Are you pretending
that you're serious again?
Well, why don't
you just smile and just --
-I am.
-What are you doing?
That means you're being serious?
[ Both laugh ]
What does that mean?
"Sesame Street's"...
[ Laughter ]
"Sesame Street's" Elmo
is hosting a virtual playdate
to help entertain kids
during the pandemic.
Meanwhile, the Count
will help parents add up
all the pounds they've gained
during the quarantine.
[ As the Count ]
10, 20, 30 pounds.
Ha ha ha!
You ate too many cookies.
[ Normal voice ]
I don't know what that is.
I don't get it.
I don't really know
what that means.
Alright, guys, sit up.
Sit up. Here we go.
Ready? Some business news.
Disney+ has added more than
50 million subscribers
in the last five months.
That's incredible.
That's like taking all of
Quibi's subscribers
and adding 50 million.
I saw that Verizon
has now stopped
all in-home repairs
and installations
except for emergencies.
Meanwhile, parents were like,
"I'm stuck with two kids
under 10 and no Internet.
This is an emergency."
Hello!
Hey, put your hand on top of my
hand and say, "Wing-wing."
-Wing-wing.
-Hello?
-I'm gonna do that.
-Alright.
-Wing-wing.
-Hello?
[ Laughter ]
-Can I do that again?
-Yep, you can.
Hold on.
Let me tell a joke first.
Waffle House is starting to sell
its signature waffle mix
and sold out of it
in four hours.
The first 30 people
who bought it also got
a lipstick-stained mug and
a dried-up syrup container.
And, finally, I saw that April
is National Poetry Month
or, as parents who
are homeschooling put it,
"Merlot is red,
Bud Light is blue.
Today, mommy and daddy
need juice time, too."
There you go, everybody.
That is our monologue!
It's time for "Hashtags"!
Yay!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Hi, everybody.
It's time for "Hashtags."
We played this game online
where we give you
a subject or a topic and then we
ask you to comment on all those.
And, so, our subject was
"my quarantine superpower"
this week.
We went on Twitter,
and I put an example.
I said,
"I have the superpower --
I can start an argument
with a single look."
And, anyways, thank you,
guys, so much for submitting.
It was number 5 trending,
so thank you so much for that.
I appreciate it.
So, now I'd like to do this
week's "Hashtags."
You ready?
-Yeah.
-I'll give it to you.
You give it to Franny, okay?
This one is from @PSU-Rose.
She said, "I can tell the
U.S. Mail truck
from the UPS truck
from the FedEx truck
based only on the sound of their
engines and brakes."
-What do I do with this?
-You can stack them.
This is from @LizSin35.
"I can make my face look
like I'm fascinated
when my husband tells the
same story again."
That got a smile.
Here you go, bud.
This one's from @RoamingOceans.
Said, "Rapid wine-evaporation
capabilities."
This one's from ScottinOhio4Now.
It says, "I can make the numbers
on my scale go up every day."
Oh, that's a good power.
There you go.
-[ Laughs ]
-This one is from FedUpHumanKS.
"Convincing my kid I'm on Zoom
when I just want to be
alone for a bit."
-Um, Daddy,
why are you sitting on me?
-Who is saying that?
-Me.
-Where are you coming from?
-Behind you.
-Are you upstairs?
-Just look behind you!
Right down.
-Are you a flamingo?
-Down!
-Let's just go to
our last hashtag.
This one's from @MaryBarry80.
She says, "Is rage a
superpower?"
Those were our "Hashtags."
Thank you so much for
submitting.
I really appreciate it.